funny they take a pay cut the men so
like the women get a third of the prize
money even though the World Cup brought
in I think seven billion dollars for the
men and less than a billion for the
women and they're crazy and they get a
third of the prize money like women just
want special treatments and it's so
funny because they marketed as like
women are fighting for a right even the
old women like I I covered this
yesterday but women running in the
marathon they would say oh it's the
woman like because there was this chick
she ran the first marathon and the men
were like pulling her out of the race
and they're like she overcame but
they're pulling her out of the race
because she was a man's race she wasn't
supposed to be there